If you are an international student and you hesitate to come
study in Montreal
this video is clearly for you
So it's been a few years
now that I'm going to Montreal
and here it is
the 5 reasons why
I do not regret having left France
to come
study
in Montreal
So my school career here is pretty simple
I made 1 Bachelor
therefore 1 Bachelor of Business Administration
uh at the Université du Québec in Montreal so to Lucas
in finance And then I decided to go to master
Now I'm in my first year as a financial general
in schuster Montreal
The 1st reason I would say
it's really the mentality of the teachers
because they are really not there to block you
they really want you to succeed
So it's really not difficult to have 1
1 plus in 1 class if you studied the subject
Reason N° 2 price flexibility
So you have 4 to 5 classes a week
so that's 12 to 15 hours of classes per week
Uh,
so you can choose your schedule
In fact you can choose your schedule
you can modulate your schedule so it suits you
And what's good about it
is that for example
you can decide to start your classes while
beginning of the week
so Monday Tuesday
to Monday Wednesday but good Tuesday Tuesday
And then the rest of the week
you can work and make money
reason N° 3 me
I would say that
it's really easy to find a job here
in your field of study
For example
I worked at the bank for 3 years
so throughout my Bachelor year
and I know that in France it would have been
it would not have been possible
Uh because I don't have a BTS in the bank so Uh Here it is
reason N° 4 I would say that it is the mentality
at the educational level
Because it is true that to find 1 job
yes,
there are studies that count,
the degree counts
but there are also the professional experiences
So we really put the in front
a lot about work experiences
And that makes here uh
You don't have to go to the baccalaureate plus 5
Honestly you don't have to
You can go very well in baccalaureate plus 3
finish in baccalaureate plus 3
find 1 job and after a few years
direct you to bac plus 5
You don't have to link up,
uh All of a sudden
In fact Reason N° 5
I would say the opportunities after school
and the salaries that we are offered Here you go